bill and Jennifer are with us hey guys
how are ya good god where do you live
for Worth Texas welcome to Nashville
good to have you good to be here and you
got your debt free t-shirts on yes we do
change the family tree yes sir very well
done a whole theme going I love it very
cool how much a debt of you guys paid
off we paid off a hundred and fifty five
thousand seven hundred dollars and six
very hard-fought ears Wow
in this year alone we paid off the last
thirty two thousand so the week ago know
ye and pay in cash it's for our 20th
anniversary that'll work so when do you
head know ye oh we've been and come back
Oh already you know that okay excellent
the cash load average household incomes
is that six years or the rings we've
started around one hundred and ten and
we're gonna top 200 this year excellent
what do you guys do for a living I'm an
engineer she's a psychologist Oh fine
very good good for you guys so what kind
of debt was this one hundred and fifty
six thousand one hundred and twenty six
of it was my graduate student loans and
I got doc itis and we bought a brand new
car when I graduated and started making
lots of bad choices about cars and so it
was pretty much student loan and car
debt mm okay so tell me the story what
happened six years ago and what happened
during this six years you know it really
started a little bit further back than
that even but and our church was doing a
Bible study and they challenged us to
write out all the debts that we had and
it totaled just under two hundred
thousand and all of a sudden I couldn't
breathe
and I was pregnant with our middle son
and we knew we needed to do something
but they really didn't give us a plan
for what to do and so we just kind of
wandered around for a while paying a
little bit of debt here and there and
then I found your book and fell in love
with your dry sarcastic humor that fits
me very well
and I came home and told bill I said we
need to follow this guy he knows what
he's talking about and bill said yeah
you do whatever you want it's okay and
but he really wasn't on board um
probably about a year later our church
was doing FPU and I said we're gonna go
and that second lesson where you talk
about getting out of debt
hooked us and we we really paid off a
lot of debt during that class and then
the last week we found out we were
pregnant with this guy yeah which means
we put everything on hold and we have
lots of medical problems that year and
he had an on our middle son had an
unexpected surgery that year so we were
able to cashflow everything but we made
no progress by the time we got through
with that year we were really off target
and had lost our focus and somehow
rationalize buying a brand-new pickup
truck on payments and so we start again
yeah we start again and it took us a
probably about a year and a half to say
you know what we got off track somewhere
and we failed FPU let's take it again so
thank you for the lifetime membership
we've gone through a couple times now so
we went back through and the third week
I looked at bill and said we gotta sell
your truck it's federal law right we
actually talked to our a few advisors
and we laid out everything we had in
front of us
finance wise and he and they unanimously
advised us that we should get rid of the
truck and I now have a 20 year old car
that we pay cash for there you go it's a
BMW but still it's 20 years old that's
cool very cool
good yeah good well and of course now
you're out of debt you make 200 thousand
a year you build up and get a truck and
we have started we have started the
replacement car absolutely very good the
big four yeah absolutely so really what
you're saying is is a lot of life
happened and you started to stopped a
couple of times
mm-hmm and took a step back a few times
like mother mae-eye penalty steps almost
and and there was a lot of times we
would listen to the debt-free screams
and I would get discouraged because you
know we hadn't had this seamless perfect
journey you know we started and stopped
and started and stopped but we were
still making progress we we kept at it
and we kept doing it and at the end of
the day here we are that's it's a great
feeling you make the trip I mean you
know some sometimes you go around the
barn to get there but you make the trip
that's the big thing so congratulations
yeah and you know what that story is is
what's called real that really happened
I mean it's not it's not a perfect Ken
and Barbie
tene you know so good news and good news
you made it one of the things that
really is inspiring to me is when you
talk about changing your family tree
because I'm a product of four
generations of debt of bankruptcies of
repossessions of foreclosures of doing
everything wrong and I was brought up
believing that you're always gonna have
a car payment that student loans are
smart money because the interest is low
and so take your money and invest it
somewhere else my dad still thinks we're
very foolish for paying my student loans
off early because we could invest that
money and make more interest but we
finally feel like we've got some piece
and we've got some control very cool you
have changed your family tree yeah yeah
and we know that because our kids they
work they be tourists they save their
money they cruise the deals online and
they're saving their little pennies for
Legos and games and things like that and
searching on eBay and how can we save
money and can we in fact this summer
they are they are my janitorial staff at
my heart yeah that's a good thing yeah
so bill what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is just to keep
persistent with it too even though you
may step back to keep focused on to keep
the end goal and thing and we had our
20th anniversary coming up and so that
was a time stamp for us to go for and to
go for that and now tell my wife even if
it takes longer than that we are still
gonna get there yeah and we did we were
able to go on an anniversary I love it
debt free which is great it was a great
trip that's fabulous although why he's
no slouch that's for sure well done good
job you guys know what are the kids
names and ages so we have Lexie who's 10
and benjamin who's 8 and the nickel is 5
very good have they been practicing
since Fort Worth we have been practicing
for probably six months all right so
they can do a debt free scream we're
gonna try to break your microphone good
because I don't like wimpy dad free
scream we vote on them at home when we
hear them on the radio
like you know in the Olympics you know
yeah you give them a 999 yeah the
Russian time is fixed yeah that's good
all right count it down here we go bill
Jennifer Lexi Ben and
your Nicholai Nicholai I'm sorry
$156,000 paid off in six years making a
hundred and ten to two hundred a year
count it down let's hear it alright
three two one praise Jesus well you
didn't break the microphones but you did
over modulate them well done that's
perfect you guys after six years you
deserve to yell that's how it works